kommandoübergabe in Amstetten am Freitag
erklingen die Worte
zum letzten Mal aus seinem Mund Oberst
rudolf-halbertschlager übergibt nach
sieben Jahren an der Spitze des Jäger
Bataillon 12 das Kommando an seinen
Nachfolger oberstleute und des
generalstabsdienstes Christian heiser
ich übergebe die Fahne
und damit die Verantwortung für das
jägerpartagame 12 eine Übergabe die dem
scheidenden Kommandanten offensichtlich
alles andere als leichtfeld es ist heute
schwierigste Tag in diesen sieben Jahren
vielleicht erstmalig
knapp daran bin die Fassung zu verlieren
ich bitte um Entschuldigung Frau
Bundesminister sie haben hier einen
rührseligen Bataillonskommandanten vor
sich der aber versuchen wir die
Disziplin zu waren Nachfolger Christian
heiser betont in seiner antriebsrede die
Einsatzbereitschaft des Jägerbataillon
12 Ihnen
dass die Soldatinnen und Soldaten des
jägerpartement 12 auch weiterhin alles
Notwendige dafür tun werden dass dies
auch in Zukunft so bleiben wird
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
verweist in ihrer Rede auf die kommenden
Herausforderungen und würdig die
Führungsqualitäten des scheidenden
Kommandanten und es wurde nicht nur
heute spürbar dass sie neben diesen
Führungsqualitäten auch über ein
unglaublich großes Herz verfügen für
ihre Soldatinnen und Soldaten die ihnen
anvertraut waren und sind aber auch für
die gesamte Region hier
danke für eure Freundschaft
als meine Soldaten ich wünsche euch
alles gute Frau Bundesminister ich melde
mich ab
[Applaus]